a new survey finds that more than half
of Republicans support Christian
nationalism at least to some degree this
is really really scary when we talk
about Christian nationalism we are
talking about having a civil government
that is based on a particular religion
in this case of Christian nationalism
we're talking about Christianity this is
extraordinarily scary and not only that
it is the opposite of what the founding
fathers wanted you will often hear from
Republicans and religious rightists oh
well all of the founding fathers were
religious so they wanted a mixing of
church and state no neither of those
claims are true some of the founding
fathers were religious some were what is
called deists and it is really not
religious in the way that the modern
Christians claim it to be but they very
clearly did not want religion and
government intertwined